the main causes of death and premature
death worldwide are from non
communicable chronic diseases including
cancer cardiovascular disease diabetes
and chronic respiratory disease and the
main causes of those disease are
behaviors which include smoking
excessive consumption of alcohol food
and physical inactivity earlier this
year the World Health Assembly pledged
to reduce those diseases by twenty-five
percent by 2025 a laudable ambition but
that's going to require major shifts in
behavior worldwide there is common
interventions that have been tried over
the last two three decades involved
giving people information about the
risks from engaging in these health
damaging behaviors it becomes
unsurprising when we look at recent
findings from psychology and
neuroscience that these aren't having
the effects that people expected because
these latest findings are telling us
that much of our behavior is not subject
to reflective processes it's actually
occurring mainly automatically without
people's awareness and it doesn't mean
that we're behaving randomly but rather
our behavior is being guided by what
we've done in the past or by the
activation of ideas that appeal to us or
actually behavior that in our
environment is going to be the most easy
thing to do
various experiments show that food that
is placed further away is less likely to
be selected and some experiments we have
quite a precise idea of how large the
effect is say food that is more than 10
inches away from somebody is twelve
percent less likely to be selected
another approach is to try to change the
association's that are activated by
environmental stimuli say one recent
example that's been much discussed as
being the removal of branding on
cigarettes and say we know that the
branding on cigarettes increases the
attractiveness particularly young people
of cigarettes and similarly we know that
the branding on fast food increases the
attractiveness to children as well as
adults so removing that kind of branding
can reduce the attractiveness of
unhealthier products and the trick now
is to find ways of increasing the
attractiveness of healthier products so
one particular example a study conducted
with three year old children was able to
increase the chances that they tried a
lentil stew by just changing the name so
the lentil stew is described either as
healthy stew or as teddy bears porridge
and when it was described as teddy bears
porridge forty percent of these three
year olds tried it compared with just I
think the twenty-five percent who tried
it when it was described as a health
east you an example of an intervention
that changes in the environment in order
to try to change people's behavior to
shape up people's behavior say that it's
healthier involves making lifts less
convenient so if you slow down the speed
at which lift doors close then
eventually people get fed up and they'll
use the stairs
one of the barriers to implementing this
approach changing changing environments
in order to change behavior is that most
of our economies are built on
consumption some would say excessive
consumption say consumption of tobacco
food alcohol fossil-fueled transport say
attempting to you reduce consumption of
these products is certainly going to
improve health but it's going to
challenge economies that are
traditionally built on this focusing on
the automatic basis too much behavior is
quite a threat to how many people think
about human action most people think
that they are in control of their
behavior that what they do should not be
controlled by others by governments
regulating to change their environments
I think that much could be done by
increasing people's understanding of
psychology and neuroscience say that
people didn't see this a threat but had
just a better understanding of our
behavior say that they were able to see
that some attempts to change
environments and not trying to control
people but actually providing them with
a better environment in which to realize
what our values and goals that most of
us hold very dear ie being healthy
you